we're now only around three months away
from Apple's September event where we're
expecting Apple to reveal their brand
new 10th Generation budget iPad and in
this video I'm gonna try to answer the
question that's on a lot of people's
minds right now will the new iPad 10
come with a full redesign just like we
got with all of the other iPads like the
iPad Pro the iPad Air and the iPad Mini
or will Apple choose to stick around
with the old design for just another
year and this is a very important
question because it can and should
easily make or break somebody's decision
on whether to wait until this new iPad
is out or buy something right now like
the current iPad 9 on sale for 309 on
Amazon well in this video I'm I'm going
to work through a bunch of leaks and
combine that with common sense and some
key points from Apple's previous iPad
lineup strategy to give you guys my own
personal prediction for if apple is
going to redesign the iPad this year and
what that'll mean for the pricing and
the features so let's get started first
of all before I get into the exclusive
new leaks from nine to five Mac I want
to make the point that Apple's budget
iPad is essentially like the youngest
kid in the family who receives all of
the hand-me-downs from the older
siblings for example the budget iPad 9
comes with the pretty old a13 chip which
first showed up in the iPhone 11 back in
2019. it was also the very last iPad in
the entire lineup to finally get
upgraded from 32 gigs of Base storage up
to 64. and that makes sense because it's
only 329 dollars hence why everyone
calls it the budget iPad and this
hand-me-down point is at actually going
to be incredibly useful for this video
because we can take a look in the past
and see how long it took for some of the
main features to make its way from
Apple's high-end iPads over to the
budget iPad and then take what we
learned there and apply that to the
whole redesign debacle and for these
comparisons I want to stick to the
smaller sized iPad Pro and the iPad Air
because it's the most similar to the
current budget iPad now getting started
apple pencil support came to the 9.7
inch iPad Pro and early 2016 and it only
came to the 6th gen budget iPad in early
2018. so that took about two years to
make its way down moving on in early
2019 the iPad Air 3 received the a12
chip which only made its way down to the
budget iPad 8 in late 2020 which is
about a one and a half year difference
the iPad Air 3 was also the first Air
Model to come come with 64 gigs of Base
storage and it wasn't until late 2021
when the current budget iPad 9 started
coming with 64 gigs which is a two and a
half year difference on top of that the
air 3 also received the true tone
display which didn't come to the budget
iPad until this current iPad 9 which is
also a two and a half year difference so
if we take all of that and average it
out it seems like a lot of the
hand-me-downs take around two to two and
a half years to make their way down to
the budget iPad now before I apply that
to the timeline of when each iPad
received a full flat sided redesign I
want to bust out the recent leaks and
rumors we got concerning the budget iPad
10 and see if those timelines match up
first of all we got a leak from the king
of Apple display leaks Ross young who
has been banging on with exact display
detail leaks in the past including the
14 and 16 inch MacBook Pro displays the
8.3 inch had mini 6 display and even the
13.6 inch M2 MacBook Air and recently he
claimed that the new iPad is going to be
getting a 10.5 inch display while the
iPad Air will remain at 10.9 which
totally makes sense because Apple wants
the more expensive iPads to have larger
displays now if that 10.5 inch display
size sounds familiar it should because
that's precisely the display size of the
iPad Air 3 and 2019 and not only that
but the entire chassis and the 10.5 inch
display on the air 3 was actually a
hand-me-down from the 2017 iPad Pro so
looking at timelines it took two years
to get handed down from the iPad Pro to
the iPad Air and then if this budget
iPad 10 this year gets that display that
would be a three and a half year Gap so
I can totally see it being overdue for a
10.5 inch display upgrade regardless of
whether it actually gets a full redesign
or not now moving on to nine to five Max
exclusive leaks they reported that the
new iPad will come with the A14 ship 5G
USBC and a retina display of the same
resolution as the iPad Airs display so
let's look at each of those points the
A14 chip totally makes sense because
that's the chip that the iPad Air 4 got
back in late 2020 so if the new iPad 10
gets it that's a two-year difference
which is spot on and now in terms of the
USBC Port the iPad Pro originally got it
in late 2018 and then it was handed down
two years later to the iPad Air 4 in
late 2020 and now if the iPad 10 gets it
that would be another two years which
actually lines up pretty well and the
most important detail that you need to
realize is that whenever an iPad
received the USBC port in the past it
always came hand in hand with a full
redesign so if this year's iPad 10 comes
with a redesign that would be a solid
two years since the iPad Air 4 which I
believe lines up quite well to all of
the other hand-me-down comparisons that
I made in this video so with that said I
want to dig into the common sense
evidence both for and against the idea
of the iPad 10 receiving a redesign this
year before I give you guys my final
prediction first of all this is going to
be the 10th generation iPad which is
kind of perfect because Apple waited
until the 10th anniversary iPhone to
give it a massive redesign with
stainless steel bands and face ID but
the number one reason why it makes sense
for this iPad to get a redesign is
because the exclusive information from
nine to five Mac has been very reliable
in the past and the fact that their
sources believe the USBC Port is coming
to the budget iPad it is a huge deal
because in the past USBC ports were only
ever added to iPads if and when they
received a full flat-sided redesign and
the reason this makes sense is because
the USBC Port is fairly fragile since
it's a female connector that also has a
floating male component in the middle of
the port which can potentially get
damaged compared to lightning which is
fully female and can't really get
damaged for example there have been
cases where actual USBC ports became
loose over time and eventually even
damaged requiring full replacement of
the port itself instead of Simply buying
a new cable which shows that USBC isn't
as reliable as Lightning so if this new
iPad 10 comes with a new USBC Port while
reusing the old chamfer chassis design
it would cause major problems because
the USBC Port would be cut diagonally
into the rounded frame so if you plug in
a USBC cable the bottom side wouldn't
have as much support as the top top
leading to a potentially loose cable
which would break the internal
components and because of this I fully
believe that the iPad absolutely needs
flat sides so that the USBC Port is
completely flat and level on the side of
the iPad making for the most stable and
reliable connection and that's why I
think Apple only ever added USBC
alongside a full redesign not only that
but if Apple wants to discontinue the
first gen apple pencil the iPad also
needs a full flat sided redesign to
support the magnetic wireless charging
feature so with that said it seems very
likely that we get a full redesign this
year but keep in mind that when Apple
redesigned the iPad Pro they raised the
price by a hundred and fifty dollars and
then the same thing for both the iPad
mini and the iPad Air both raised by a
hundred dollars so a redesign for the
budget iPad would likely mean that the
price will go up to 399 dollars for the
iPad 10 which I think is completely
reasonable because the redesign will be
a huge deal since it'll honestly
cannibalize the sales of the more
expensive iPad Air especially since the
A14 chip is more than powerful enough
for a lot of people and on top of that
redesigning the iPad 10 makes sense
because it'll allow Apple to sell even
more second gen Apple pencils since the
first gen ones will no longer be
supported forcing people to upgrade to
the new one with wireless charging
support and not only that but they could
even make a new magic keyboard case for
the 10.5 inch size to sell even more
accessories and of course all of the
USBC Chargers adapters and accessories
that Apple sells as well however there
is a chance that Apple doesn't redesign
the iPad 10 this year because as we all
know this year's iPhone 14 lineup will
continue to use lightning until next
year with the iPhone 15 when they're
finally going to switch to USBC so if
Apple wanted to they could totally wait
on a full budget iPad redesign until
next year and this could also make sense
for Apple because it would boost the
sales of the more expensive iPads right
now that do have the redesign and
there's also the fact that Apple could
easily reuse this same 10.5 inch chassis
with the old design from both the 2019
iPad Air and the 2017 iPad Pro which
would be the cheapest and easiest route
for an incremental update but that would
of course mean no USBC Port this year
but in terms of my personal prediction I
have a feeling that nine to five Max
sources are right about USBC coming to
the budget iPad this year which I think
means that we will be getting a full
redesign and you should definitely wait
three more months until that iPad comes
out before you make any major iPad
purchasing decisions so hopefully this
video was helpful and if it was
definitely click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]